foreign
excuse me
sir we're officers of the law you're
gonna run me in I don't feel like
talking I'm distraught hey Benny you
want to ask this guy some questions all
right what is this what's this
Arrangement Mr Drysdale
CSI KFC
hey there I'm Mark and welcome back to
RT Essentials time to break out the deer
stalker hat and dust off the old
magnifying glass because today we're
discussing the finest whodunit films and
it doesn't take Sherlock to uncover the
reasons why this genre has long been
cherished and only seems to be rising in
popularity these titles speak for
themselves now you might be wondering
what makes a film of who done it and not
just a regular old mystery and the
answer is simple anything inexplicable
can fall into the category of mystery
and though whodunits are technically
Mysteries they tend to focus on a
specific crime where the culprit
revealed much later in the film
everybody got that so in a sense we all
get together and solve the puzzle and
really what's more fun than that these
are the best who've done it movies
Gosford Park nice to come to Trenton yes
I served with your husband my
brother-in-law Lord Stockbridge lady
Stockbridge Jennings please would you
remove that vile animal
uh Mrs Nesbitt uh Mr Nesbitt Iva novello
but I'm sure need to know well of course
Mr developer no wait wait would you like
to speak to servants tonight Inspector
Inspector I think he ought to speak to
private my husband's about it would you
tell him to come up now where was I um
up first it's 2001's Gosford Park
directed by Robert Altman and written by
Julian fellows said in 1930s England a
wealthy family invites a group of rich
and famous guests to their country
estate Gosford Park for a weekend of
relaxation and hunting when a mysterious
murder occurs each one of these
eccentric characters becomes a suspect
and like most whodunits it's often the
person we at least expect though the
guests above stairs have plenty of
possible motives to commit such a crime
we mustn't forget about the staff below
stairs like the butler Mr Jennings or
the head housekeeper Mrs Wilson also the
victim was poisoned so you gotta be
suspicious of Mrs Croft the cook Mr
Weissman tell us about the film you're
going to make oh sure it's called
Charlie Chan in London it's a detective
story set in London well not really most
of it takes place at a shooting Party In
A Country House sort of like this one
actually uh murder in the middle of the
night a lot of guests for the weekend
everyone's a suspect that sort of thing
Orange Let's recap we have an opulent
English Estate with a cool name a
wealthy family their staff and various
guests with interconnecting drama does
this scenario sound familiar at all it
will if you're a fan of the drama series
Downton Abbey which was created by
Julian fellows who as I mentioned
earlier wrote the script for this film
though Downton Abbey is set earlier in
the 20th century it was originally
intended to be a spin-off of Gosford
Park But ultimately ended up being a
standalone series for his work on this
film fellows won the Oscar for best
original screenplay and additionally
Gosford Park received Oscar nominations
for Best Picture best director and best
supporting actress murder on the Orient
Express ten thousand
fifteen thousand Mr ratchet I have made
enough money to set his fire both my
needs and my capacity I take only such
cases now as interests me and to be
frank my interest in your case is uh
dwindling
murder on the Orient Express is a 1974
film directed by Sydney lumet and based
on the Agatha Christie novel of the same
name seems like a good time to tip our
hashtag at the Christie the queen of
crime who penned 66 mystery novels and
14 short story collections during her
career and was largely responsible for
the rise in popularity of whodunit
novels during the 1920s and the 1930s
also known as the Golden Age of
detective fiction this film follows
Belgian detective percule Perot who
having recently concluded a case heads
home aboard the Orient Express train
what he had hoped would be a relaxing
journey of course things go off the
rails pretty quickly when an unpopular
billionaire is murdered on the route
Perot takes on the case and realizes
that several passengers on the train
have Revenge as a mode in the ultimate
suicide
and you would have understood his action
if in addition to the DSO MC he had been
awarded the VC
which stands as you may know for
Victoria Cross and is awarded favela
then in my opinion
that you deserve what he got Agatha
Christie attended the film's premiere in
November of 1974. 84 years young at the
time and this was apparently the only
movie adaptation of her work that she
felt satisfied with during her lifetime
noting that Albert Finney's performance
of her character Poirot was sufficient
except for one major mistake in the
novel perrow is known for having the
finest mustache in England and Finney's
mustache just didn't cut it too bad they
couldn't have fixed it with CGI you know
like that mustache gate from Superman
maybe it's better that they didn't
Tinker with it clue she's not here
I didn't do it's not just a game anymore
was the tagline from the 1985 black
comedy clue written and directed by
Jonathan Lynn fans of the board game
were thrilled to see their favorite
characters brought to life on the Silver
Screen like Mrs peacock Miss Scarlett
Professor Plum and of course Colonel
Mustard just like the game the movie's
objective was to figure out who murdered
the dinner host Mr body where the crime
took place and which weapon was used the
six strangers in the film all given
pseudonyms arrived by invitation to an
ominous New England Mansion where they
are the Mr body is threatening to
Blackmail them and expose their darkest
Secrets not six one plus two plus two
plus one uh-uh it was only one shot that
got the chandelier that's one plus two
plus one plus one even if you were right
that would be one plus one plus two plus
one not one plus two plus one plus one
okay fine one plus two plus one
point is there's one bullet left in this
gun and guess who's gonna get body then
gives each guest a weapon a Candlestick
a knife a lead pipe a revolver a rope
and a wrench and suggest that someone
kills Wadsworth the bowler pointing out
that Wadsworth has the key to the front
door and that his death will ensure that
no one but the seven of them will ever
know of their secrets when Mr body turns
out the lights a gunshot is heard and
when the lights are turned back on Mr
body is dead it's a dead body get it
clue is considered groundbreaking at the
time for featuring three different
endings each theater would receive and
play one of those three endings a
marketing tactic which kind of backfired
because clue ended up being a box office
failure but hey the film later developed
a massive cult following and let's not
forget this was the first movie ever
based on a board game and as a guy who
rewatched it last week it's still great
Knives Out I spoke in the car about the
hole at the center of this donut
and what you and Holland did that
fateful night seems at first glance to
fill that hole perfectly a donut hole in
a donut hole
but we must look a little closer
and when we do we see the donut hole has
a hole in its Center it is not a donut
hole but a smaller donut with its own
hole and our donut is not whole at all
knives that was written and directed by
Ryan Johnson Who Rose to prominence
following the success of his film's
Looper and that little Space Opera you
might have heard of called Star Wars The
Last Jedi which grossed over a billion
dollars Johnson was already a force to
be reckoned with but he somehow managed
to outdo himself with this one and it
was no accident as he conceptualized
Knives Out way back in 2005 14 years
before its release in 2019. the film
features an All-Star cast which includes
Daniel Craig Chris Evans Jamie Lee
Curtis and Tony Collette and it centers
around the mysterious circumstances
surrounding the death of crime novelist
Harlan thrombi the brilliant detective
Benoit Blanc played by Craig must sit
through a Web of Lies and red Harry's to
uncover the truth and deal with the
wildly dysfunctional thrombi family in
the process we are the thrombies god
this is still our house
oh sorry
likewise the house at two Dearborn Drive
in all belongings therein I leave to
Marta Cabrera
did you know about this were you in on
this from this building I just want to
know what were you what were you doing
were you pointing my father though
Knives Out deliberately touches on
classic whodunit tropes and there are
definite similarities between detective
Blanc and Paro aka the mustache guy this
film stands out for being contemporary
and presenting relatable conflicts as
opposed to the period pieces that
dominate this particular genre the
decision was partially inspired by the
work of you guessed it Agatha Christie
who in her time was ready to
contemporary British Society according
to Johnson the notion of taking this
genre and plugging it into Contemporary
American society seemed like it could
maybe yield some fresh things and right
he was Knives Out was unanimously
praised by critics and earned bafta and
Oscar nomination her best original
screenplay it was also a box office
success and was named after a badass
Radiohead song so really what more do
you need LA Confidential that's right
our motives are selfish
so we're cooperating so cooperate Miss
Bracken why was Susan Lefferts at the
night owl I don't know I never heard of
the Night Owl till today how did she
meet Patrick Pierce meets people
Sue came on a bus with dreams of
Hollywood and this is how they turned
out
thanks to pierce
we still get to act a little LA
Confidential is in 1997 neo-noir crime
drama directed produced and co-written
by Curtis Hanson and based on the novel
of the same name it's a story of three
policemen each with their own motives
and obsessions who set out to tackle the
corruption surrounding an unsolved
robbery and multiple homicides out of
downtown Los Angeles coffee shop in the
early 1950s once again this whodunit
boasts a superb cast which includes
Russell Crowe Guy Pierce and Kim
Basinger as the film was being developed
Crow and Pierce were relatively unknown
in America and their producers were
worried about the lack of stars in the
leading roles remember this was
pre-gladiator the film that would watch
Crow went to Superstars thankfully
Hansen stuck to his guns and now it's
hard to imagine anyone else in these
roles when it came to the source
material Hanson had taken an interest in
James elroy's novel not because of the
plot but because of the characters
according to Hansen what hooked him on
the characters was that as he met them
one after another he didn't like them
but as he continued reading he started
to care about them how's it going to
look in your report it'll look like
justice that's what the man got
Justice he didn't know the meaning of
the word
yeah
you think it means getting your picture
in the paper why don't you go after
criminals for a change instead of cops
Stenson got what he deserved and so will
you
so with that in mind Hanson teamed up
with screenwriter Brian helgelin and the
two wrote a screenplay in which the
characters came first and the plot was
lightly taken from elroy's novel LA
Confidential was a critical and
Commercial Success earning nine Oscar
nominations and winning for best
supporting actress facing her and best
adapted screenplay yes Russell Crowe
thank you we were in fact entertained
The Usual Suspects first thing on the
job you know what I learned how to spot
a Murderer let's say you arrest three
guys for the same killing you put them
all in jail overnight the next morning
whoever's sleeping is your man you see
if you're guilty you know you're caught
you get some rest you let your guard
down you follow me no
let me get right to the point
I'm smarter than you
and I'm gonna find out what I want to
know
and I'm going to get it from you whether
you like it or not
I'm not a rat next up it's The Usual
Suspects a gritty crime Thriller
directed by Brian Singer and written by
Christopher macquarrie the film follows
five low-key criminals who had
unknowingly wronged one of the most
enigmatic crime Wards of all time Kaiser
Soze in order to make amends for their
wrongdoings the five criminals were
ordered to raid a ship and Destroy 91
million dollars worth of cocaine being
sold on board things go horribly wrong
when an explosion destroys the boat and
27 people end up dead these events
unfold in flashbacks as the criminals
are interrogated by a tough Customs
agent Named Dave kujin played by Chaz
Palminteri of all the whodunits on this
list The Usual Suspects might have the
biggest twist one that will leave even
the most Adept movie detectives with
their jaws hitting the floor do you
believe in him verbal
Keaton always said
I don't believe in God
but I'm afraid of him
well I believe in God
and the only thing that scares me
is Kaisers but as shocking as the twist
is the clues are hidden in plain sight
all along you should apologize to your
TV in advance for the yelling you'll
undoubtedly be directing towards it
mostly out of embarrassment that you
like me and all of us watching it for
the first time got duped that's all I'm
gonna say about it no spoiler is giving
away here the first visual idea singer
had for the film was five guys who meet
in a lineup this got him thinking what
would possibly bring these five felons
together Macquarie had been working on a
script about a murderer who disappears
which he revamped to incorporate
singer's vision of a team of criminals
and boom The Usual Suspects was born the
film won two Oscars was a critical and
Commercial Success and is considered one
of the greatest mysteries of all time
Who Framed Roger Rabbit get him out of
there or steal him up in it lose the
lights and say lunch it's lunch
[Music]
don't worry about me I'm not worried
about you I'm worried about the
refrigerator
[Music]
blending live action with animation Who
Framed Roger Rabbit Stars Bob Hoskins as
Eddie Valiant a down on his left private
eye who gets hired by cartoon producer
r.k maroon to investigate an adultery
Scandal involving Jessica Rabbit the
wife of Roger Rabbit but things take a
turn when the owner of Toontown is found
murdered and now Valiant must help
exonerate Roger Rabbit who's been framed
for the crime the film was directed by
Robert zemeckis and is Loosely adapted
from the 1981 Gary K Wolf novel who
censored Roger Rabbit Walt Disney
Productions purchased the film rights to
the novel shortly after it was published
and a few years later Disney approached
Steven Spielberg's production company
amblin entertainment to co-produce
giving them an extensive amount of
creative control Spielberg originally
wanted Harrison Ford for the role of
Eddie Valiant the Ford was too pricey
and Eddie Murphy turned down the role
because he didn't really understand the
concept of humans coexisting with
cartoons a decision that he later
regretted several months ago I have a
good Providence to stumble upon land of
the city councils a construction plan of
epic proportions
they are calling it a freeway
freeway
but the freeway eight Lanes of
shimmering cement running from here to
Pasadena smooth safe fast and traffic
jams will be a thing of the past so
that's why you kill that new Maroon for
this freeway additionally Robin Williams
Jack Nicholson and Sly Stallone were all
considered but Spielberg ultimately
chose Hoskins noting that he had a
hopeful demeanor and walked like he
belonged in that 1940s era to achieve
such an eye-popping spectacle
326 animators worked full time during
production and animation director
Richard Williams estimated that over 1
million drawings had to be done for the
film though Disney was initially
concerned about the rising budget which
exceeded 50 million dollars Who Framed
Roger Rabbit proved to be worthy of the
undertaking the film grossed over 350
million bucks won three Oscars and was
called a breakthrough in craftsmanship
by Roger not rabbit Ebert
seven protect it
after this
no big surprise
you're looking for me
I know you now get out get down on your
stomach David Fincher 7 is widely
considered to be one of the greatest
serial killer movies of all time the
plot follows retiring police detective
William Somerset who tackles his final
case with the aid of the newly transfer
detective David Mills after they
discover a number of elaborate and
grisly murders they realize they are
dealing with a sophisticated killer who
is targeting people he thinks represent
one of the seven deadly sins much like
The Usual Suspects this film comes with
a surprise ending the bad kind of
surprise like actually the worst kind of
surprise imaginable again I'm not here
to spoil the party but trust me when I
say you do not want to know what's in
the box screenwriter Andrew Walker was
influenced by his time spent in New York
and he was convinced that the script for
seven was far too dark to ever sell it
was kind of right because new line
Cinema wanted to make the film but
rejected Walker's original what's in the
box ending and they had Walker write an
alternate more traditional ending
unfortunately for new line they
accidentally sent Fincher the old draft
and Fincher was set on keeping Locker's
original Landing I'll show you with the
Box what was in the Box because I envy
your normal life Put the gun down babe
it seems that Envy is myself oh what's
in the box
give me the gun
you lied you're a [ __ ] liar shut up
that's what he wants see what he wants
you to shoot him no no
you tell me you tell me that's not true
that's not true the conventions did not
that wasn't all Brad Pitt also refused
to make the movie if the ending was
changed Going as far as putting that
condition in his contract okay I've
blabbed enough about the ending of seven
but I suggest you watch the movie to
fill in the rest of these gory details
Chinatown there's a waterlog drunk in
the morgue involuntary manslaughter if
anybody wants to take the trouble which
they don't it seems like half the city
is trying to cover it all up which is
fine by me
Mrs Maury I got lost my nose and I like
it I like breathing through it and I
still think that you're hiding something
next up is Chinatown a 1974 neo-nor
Thriller written by Robert Towne set in
1937 Jack Nicholson stars as private eye
Jake Getz who was hired by Evelyn mulray
to investigate her husband's activities
and what he believes is a routine
infidelity case Jake's investigation
soon becomes anything but routine when
he meets the real Mrs mulray played by
Faye Dunaway and realizes he was hired
by an imposter when Mr mole Ray's body
is found in a reservoir gets ends up on
a tangled trail of corruption deceit and
Sinister family secrets Robert Talon's
script was inspired by the California
Water Wars which were a series of
political conflicts that erupted in the
early 20th century between the city of
Los Angeles and farmers in eastern
California I don't blame myself
[Music]
see Mr gitz most people never have to
face the fact the right time in the
right place they're capable of
Performing everything
[Music]
take those glasses from him will you
[Music]
just really not worth it Town wrote the
script and its main protagonist with
Nicholson in mind and Nicholson was on
board even before a director was
attached the script was that good as a
matter of fact it's considered to be one
of the greatest if not the greatest
scripts ever written and one town the
Oscar for best original screenplay at
the 47th Academy Awards Chinatown is
like a master class on how to make a who
done it and its influence can be seen in
subsequent films like Devil in a Blue
Dress drive and of course LA
Confidential and also as Who Framed
Roger Rabbit in there as well Memento
you don't know who you are I'm Leonard
Shelby I'm from San Francisco
you want to know Lenny
come on come on let's go down the
basement
let's go down you and me together
then you'll know who you really are
last but certainly not the least is
Memento written and directed by
Christopher Nolan and produced by
Suzanne and Jennifer Todd Guy Pierce
plays Leonard Shelby who is tracking
down the people who attacked and
murdered his wife this proves to be
difficult because Leonard suffers from a
rare untreatable form of memory loss
known as anterograde Amnesia although he
can recall details of his life before
his accident Leonard cannot remember
what happened 15 minutes ago or where
he's going and why he got there what
sets Memento apart from most whodunits
is the non-linear narrative structure
presented as two sequences one in black
and white and one in color so next time
you see me
will you remember me
I think you will
I'm sorry
the black and white sequences move
forward chronologically and the color
sequences move in reverse order this
gives the audience an opportunity to
empathize with Leonard and experience
the events as he does I know it sounds
confusing but let's not forget this is
the guy who made Inception and the guy
who made tenet two of the most
complicated movies ever so after you see
those this is a piece of cake and it's
Nolan's brand damn it momento was a box
office success earned two Oscar
nominations and was selected for
preservation in the National film
registry by the Library of Congress
additionally critics praised the
performances of Pierce Carrie Anne moss
and Joe pantaliana but let's be real it
was the Polaroid camera that stole the
show right and that concludes our list
of the best whodunit movies as always we
didn't have time to cover every
noteworthy selection that belongs in
this category but fear not we got plenty
of episodes of RT Essentials coming your
way so I'm sure we'll crack that case
eventually thanks for watching I'm Mark
Ellis and when it comes time to solve
your next whodunit remember what Agatha
Christie once said very few of us are
what we see
[Applause]
[Music]